bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo où nous allons parler de
la fin de moonlight de l'épisode 6 et du
coup bas de tous que cela pourrait
pourquoi pas impliqué pour l'avenir du
mc eu avant de commencer je vous
conseille de voir cette vidéo nous
parlons des grandes théories de
moonlight alors forcément vu qu'elle est
sorti à la fin de l'épisode iv donc au
milieu de la série il ya des choses qui
sont fausses bien évidemment mais étant
donné qu'on parlait de la série dans sa
globalité eh bien il ya toujours des
questions et des mystères qui sont
toujours d'actualité comme ça on va
pouvoir éviter de répéter mot pour mot
ce que je vous disais déjà dans cette
vidéo quoi d'ailleurs je m'excuse que la
vidéo ne sorte que ce dimanche 1 et pas
mercredi mais bon vu qu'ils avaient
docteur strange multiverse of madness
voilà on avait des priorités un bref
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner on a
beaucoup de travail pour les semaines à
venir là pour commencer nous pouvons
faire un rapide point sur la série dans
sa globalité par rapport aux comics etc
comme chaque série marvel bien
évidemment il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
références aux comics surtout quand il
s'agit pas de l'origine story du héros
donc soissons une histoire on va dire de
base nous retrouvons bien évidemment le
tdi le trouble dissociatif de l'identité
qui caractérise marque en tant que héros
son décès en tant que mercenaire avant
sa renaissance parc en show pour qu'il
devienne le moonlight on retrouve steven
grant les nehad et tout le délire des
dieux d'égypte marlène iron qui est ici
retranscrite en tant que leïla on
retrouve l'hôpital psychiatrique avec
leurs tripes de marques provenant des
comics de jeff mayer bref il y a
énormément d'éléments des comics
néanmoins la série s'est quand même
permis plusieurs libertés et notamment
une que je trouve intéressante c'est le
fait que leila soit l'avatar de
talloires est la déesse hippopotame qui
guident marque et steven vers l'au-delà
entre guillemets on ne va pas se mentir
c'est clair que c'est pour que le
personnage de leïla soit plus impactants
est plus important dans la série et
l'avenir du mc leïla étant la
représentation de marlène la femme de
mark et la fille du défunt archéologues
peter al ron et bien cette dernière dans
les comics est bien n'a pas beaucoup
d'impact scénaristique même si c'est une
combattante aguerris etc elle symbolise
presque la princesse entre guillemets
que le héros doit sauver dans les
premiers comics donc là c'est plutôt
intéressant leila quand elle devient une
super héroïne s'appelle the scarlet
scarab soit le scarabée écarlate c'est
une référence aux comics bien sûr le
scarabée écarlate est un super héros
égyptien provenant de vieux comics mais
en vrai il est très peu apparu il a peu
d'impact etc je trouve un bon rappel du
fait que même si les comics sont une
source d'inspiration marvel studios font
ce qu'ils veulent tout ça donne du poids
à leïla pour le mc eu d'ailleurs je
trouve que leïla est quand même un bon
personnage et il est clair du coup
désormais qu'elle aura un impact dans le
futur et puis j'ai oublié de le dire
mais et awad c pareil hein elle n'existe
pas dans les comics donc voilà
d'ailleurs c'est comme pour arthur euros
et hamit choix plutôt surprenant car
dans les comics arthur ce n'est pas un
méchant très connu de moonlight et hamit
c'est un peu la même chose parmi la
panoplie de dieu d'egypte qui existe il
ya vraiment un désir dans cette série de
créer du neuf du nouveau et du coup ça
peut vouloir dire également que les
ennemis iconique de moonlight pourront
être adaptées à l'avenir maintenant que
l'origine story est passé on le rappelle
vite fait mais voilà les mines night
sound vous êtes beaucoup à les attendre
et marvel le sait très bien et on tend
de plus en plus à les avoir un jour
blade a été teasé black knight a déjà
été introduit moon knight bah du coup
c'est fait wolf arrive pour halloween
bref il y a un gros futur pour moon
knight d'ailleurs il existe aussi un
futur pour l'univers qu'apporte moon
knight car pour le moment on se
concentre beaucoup sur le personnage est
le héros mais toutes les thématiques qui
l'entourent sont importantes c'est
l'arrivée par exemple des dieux d'égypte
des abats tard des mythes et légendes et
tout ça désormais bassin impact ces
présents et c'est arrivé dans le marc
vds cinématiques universe nous reverrons
les nehad c'est sûr notamment du fait
que seules les avatars des dieux ont été
tués néanmoins je pense que comme il y a
très longtemps il va y avoir un avant et
un après ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les dieux d'égypte sont très
anciens l'aîné had étaient composés
d'énormément de dieu et avec le temps
avec la perte de foi des humains en eux
l'aîné had a évolué ainsi que ses
membres il y à des dieux qui ont été
bannis comme coach ou par exemple il y à
des dieux qui ont été emprisonnés il y a
aussi des dieux qui ont été tuées
certainement tout ça pour dire qu'il va
y avoir un avant et un après arthur
euros allier downs l'aîné had va je
pense encore évoluer une partie de
l'humanité a désormais conscience que
les dieux égyptiens existe et se cachait
depuis tout ce temps bref c'est une
nouvelle ère qui démarre et qui dit
nouvelle ère dit possiblement une
nouvelle composition
dieu pour les nehad et cela peut vouloir
dire beaucoup pour l'avenir du mc dans
la série les nehad était composée
d'osiris le chef de l'assemblée d'horus
à tort ou encore tekna août mais il
existe plein d'autres dieux par exemple
maintenant que les dieux et leurs
avatars ont été introduits et bien je
verrais bien pourquoi pas la ds bast à
l'avenir pour refaire partie de l'enad
tout le délire du film black panther
baigne complètement dans ce que nous
apporte moon knight et je dirais même
que cela solidifie l'univers apportée
par blake panthères nous pourrions enfin
être témoin d'une représentation de bast
sachant que black panther 2 arrive en
fin d'année et qu'en plus il est certain
que le film signifie l'arrivée d'un
nouveau ou d'une nouvelle blague
panthères soit le nouvel avatar de bast
dans une prochaine production nous
pourrions alors à être témoin de la
présence de black panthères durant une
réunion de l'aîné à de pareilles moi je
verrais bien aussi le retour ou
l'arrivée de hatoum soit amon ra si je
ne dis pas de bêtises normalement je
crois qu'il est le dieu majeur d'égypte
en fait ce qui est perturbant c'est que
tout le délire des dieux égyptiens ce
n'est pas des créations de marvel cela
vient des légendes et des cultures du
monde réel sachant que le mc huet une
copie entre guillemets de notre monde
cela veut dire que c'est dieu existe
marvel studios ne peut pas les ignorer
bref c'était une parenthèse je dis ça
car je trouve curieux qu aux iris soit
le chef de l'enad alors que normalement
bas amon ra existe mais bon c'est voilà
ce n'est que ma pensée mais du coup pour
revenir à ce que je disais l'arrivée
d'un monnerat pourrait signifier
l'arrivée du sun king un antagoniste
connu et puissant de moonlight en gros
le sun king c'est l'avatar damon rats
amon ra est d'ailleurs le père de
kenshoo et son opposé puisqu'il est le
dieu du soleil sachant que comme show
est toujours banni de l'aîné had et que
pire que ça il a tué à hamit ce qui veut
dire qu'il a tué une déesse et 1 je me
demande si ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'interdît tous les dieux au civil soit
ils sont enfermés tu es une divinité est
un acte qui dépasse tout ça déjà que
coach n'est pas appréciée de l'aîné had
bref voilà quoi bon et maintenant il
faudrait quand même que nous parlions de
jake look lien on l'a quand même attendu
1 se boucle pour rappel jake est la 3ème
identité de marque dans les comics on à
marcq spector le mercenaire et identité
principal steven grant un riche play-boy
et enfin jacques look lit un magouilleur
est chauffeur de taxi il y a clairement
des discussions à avoir concernant jake
car c'est vraiment la partie mystères de
la série et du coup suite à l'épisode
final bas je vous avoue que j'ai imaginé
une belle théorie et j'espère qu'elle va
vous plaire déjà il y à deux questions
importantes à se poser est ce que coach
aux jouets de marque depuis le début de
la série est en fait jake était son
véritable avatar mais surtout comment
est née jeff klauk pour la première
question il semblerait que ce soit le
cas dans le sens où il est impossible de
faire confiance à caoutchouc marque ne
lui a jamais fait confiance steven non
plus et la fin de la série nous traduit
clairement que coach où était le grand
master mind d'ailleurs on en revient à
une précédente vidéo nous parlions du
personnage de moon knight mais le tdi
soit le trouble dissociatif de
l'identité est une aubaine pour kontchou
c'est clairement une thématique du
personnage et quand show nous le
confirme avec la fin de la série
maintenant concentrons nous sur jake on
retrouve bien évidemment les codes
instauré par les comics comme le fameux
béret le fait qu'il soit chauffeur de
taxi d'ailleurs au passage la nouvelle
tenue de comptes souvient également des
comics et petite particularité ce
dernier par l'espagnol cela sous-entend
clairement pour moi que jake est là
depuis un moment et donc qu'il possède
sa propre histoire le passé de marque
nous a démontré qu'il est un juif
américain qu'il parle arabe de par ses
expéditions en egypte et steven n'est
qu'un expert de l'egypte donc tout ce
qui est à heroes glyphes et c'est
l'espagnol traduite un passé que nous ne
connaissons pas encore et qui est propre
à jake d'ailleurs il semble que jake
dans le mc eu soit encore plus le
violent et plus puissant que marc il ne
semble pas avoir véritablement de morale
et n'hésite pas à tuer et massacrer ses
opposants ce qui veut dire qu'il y a
probablement enfin ce même sûr qu'il
existe un autre costume de moon knight
que nous découvrirons à l'avenir et
notamment que mark n'était en possession
que d'une partie des pouvoirs de kenshoo
puisque jake a détruit arthur qui était
en possession des pleins pouvoirs damit
et du coup c'est là que j'ai une théorie
à vous proposer concernant la naissance
de jake nous avons appris de par la
série que quand mark était jeune la mort
de son frère et le reniement de sa mère
a créé chez lui un traumatisme qui a
donné naissance à son trouble de
l'identité steven est alors né et deux
identités se sont partagé le même corps
or désormais nous connaissons l'histoire
de marque en détail ce dernier a ravivé
tous ces souvenirs et a pleinement
conscience de son trouble dissociatif de
l'identité et de son histoire il est le
créateur de stephen et il lui cédait le
corps dans les pires moments afin de les
éviter sauf que ce qui est troublant
c'est que mark n'a aucunement conscience
que jake existe tout comme steven et
c'est là que c'est intéressant je crois
et je suis même sûr que marc n'a pas
créé djak pourtant il vient bien de
quelque part nous savons que marx et
l'identité principal c'est lui l'origine
le premier à être dans ce corps alors
comment eh bien je dirais que jake
aurait en fait été créée par steven la
présence de steven dans le corps de marc
ne signifie pas qu'il est secondaire au
contraire les deux sont autant légitime
l'un que l'autre marque est une personne
souffrant de trouble dissociatif de
l'identité et c'est la même chose pour
steven sauf qu'étant donné que steven
est la création de marques les deux
personnages ne se pose pas plus de
questions que ça sur l'étendue de leurs
troubles ils se disent que marc est
l'origine et que du coup c'est lui qui a
la main sur tout mais ce n'est pas le
cas la naissance et la vie de steven
sont plutôt horribles quand on y pense
puisque mark se servaient de lui pour
encaisser toutes les difficultés comme
les excès de violence de leur mère ou le
fait de devoir affronter le décès de
cette dernière et par rapport à
l'introduction de steven dans la série
nous sommes témoins que ce dernier ne se
fait jamais respecté ses collègues se
moque de lui sa patronne ne le respecte
pas la vie de steven est très dur quand
on y réfléchit un petit peu et c'est là
que je me suis dit que la théorie
pourrait marcher avec tout ce que subit
steven ce dernier doit avoir énormément
de frustration en lui toute sa vie il
s'est laisser marcher dessus par sa
patronne par sa mère etc etc dans
l'épisode 2 steven nous dévoile même une
pensée intrigante quand il fait face à
arthur il nous affirme qu'il a déjà
pensé a tué sa patronne pourtant il ne
l'a jamais fait et ne le ferai jamais
car voilà steven est quelqu'un de bien
mais cela traduit une pulsion et une
frustration qu'il a en lui en donnant
inconsciemment naissance à jake qui ne
possèdent pas de morale qui a confiance
en lui et qui n'hésite pas à être
violent et tuent et jake traduirait
toute la frustration de steven une
identité qui est né et qui a été
provoquée par la souffrance de stephen
et qui expliquerait pourquoi marque n'en
a pas conscience car ce n'est pas lui
qui l'a créé à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez
et nous allons nous arrêter ici j'espère
que la vidéo vous aura plu un la
tradition oblige comme à chaque fin de
série marvel 1 on fait un peu une vidéo
mise au point analyse un petit peu
théorique et cetera et voilà je suis
content de l'avoir fait n'hésitez pas à
me faire vos retours sur la série que
vous l'ayez aimé ou non je crois que les
avis divergent beaucoup la concernant il
est vrai que les quatre premiers
épisodes ont mis un peu de temps le
cinquième épisode j'ai trouvé que
c'était vraiment une master class 1
franchement est bon le sixième c'est
vrai qu'il était quand même un petit peu
rocher mais voilà dans sa globalité j'ai
bien aimé tout le délire d'égypte qui a
été amené c'est quand même un petit vent
frais je trouve pour le mc huron change
quand même pas mal des séries
habituelles mais bon je vous avoue que
j'aurais quand même aimé avoir un petit
peu plus de références et de consistance
concernant pourquoi par rama tout
ou pourquoi pas qu'anglais conquérant un
boss qu'il y a des comics ou moon knight
et quang se sont affrontés à travers le
temps etc bref il y aurait pu y avoir
quelques petites références dans la
globalité c'était quand même sympa et
puis ça reste une origin story ne faut
pas l'oublier un mot night reviendra à
l'avenir et il est censé quand même
avoir un gros futur pour le moment on ne
sait pas s'il y aura une saison 2 mais
bon je n'y crois pas un marvel préfère
faire des one shot la série law qui est
un petit peu particulière parce qu'elles
se passent complètement hors de tout ce
qu'on connaît hors de l'univers du mca
et cetera donc voilà moon knight a plus
de chance pour moi de revenir dans un
film où ni notre production n'hésitez
pas à me dire si vous voulez qu'on
reparle de moonlight à l'avenir je pense
que si l'on creuse un petit peu il ya
moyen de dire plein d'autres choses mais
bon ça dépend vraiment de si ça vous aie
poupe à quoi n'oubliez pas le petit
pouce bleus n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner on a beaucoup de travail dans
les semaines à venir et puis écoutez pas
cet argot rock que le lay en art soit
avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]